luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and i'm here in alaska with my
family and we're spending three days
camping
fishing
floating rivers and having a great time
[Music]
you have all your um you guys ready to
do a camping trip yeah
[Music]
well this something a little different
we're going camping for about three days
and i've got the whole family with me
this is the thermarest window king xl
it's arguably the most comfortable
camping pad on the market rebecca comes
with me she gets the bundle
[Music]
i think the second most comfortable mats
on the market are these it's the sea to
summit comfort light you inflate them
out with this stuff sack
[Music]
all right there we go we got everyone
set up
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
there we go some prime rib steak
and uh bell peppers and strawberries
[Music]
here here you go baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you want a marshmallow stick yes
thank you jen
[Music]
there you go make a perfect marshmallow
for you
thank you
that's perfect nailed it nailed it well
guys we got everything set up got the
kids fed but we got to get them to bed
because it's already late but that's
okay because we are going to be camping
for three days we're going to be fishing
and rafting and doing all sorts of fun
adventures
so uh it's going to be pretty nice did
you get toothpaste
[Music]
got a bottle of hot water here i'm going
to put in mama's sleeping bag make sure
she's nice and warm tonight
i'm using farts to
parts
keep
you
you warm
okay i finally got all the kids to sleep
it's late i'm putting the camera up i'll
see you guys in the morning
come on boys up and adam up and adam
jacob
jacob
oh
we got another one
oh you're getting big
all right here we go
look there's little mini cinnamon rolls
well we're up early we're going to do a
little salmon fishing but first we got
to go through the second longest tunnel
in the united states
so we're going through the tunnel to
whittier alaska now the whittier tunnel
is about two miles long and it's a
single lane so you have to share the
tunnel with all the directions of
traffic and with the railroad so at the
bottom of the hour traffic goes into
whittier at the top of the hour traffic
comes out of whittier and the train has
its own little schedule it goes around
too so we're gonna go drive on the road
tracks
all right welcome to the town of
whittier this is not a big place
basically an apartment building a fish
processing plant and some docks but it's
a lovely little place all right we're
here let me show you the spot
this little creek has a bunch of
spawning pink salmon and the pink salmon
sit out in that lagoon waiting for high
tide to come up into this river
so i'm gonna go out there and catch some
pink salmon
time to go do some spear fishing we'll
see if i can't get something before
hypothermia sets in
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
well there we go
got three pink salmon we're gonna make
some nice smoked salmon with these bad
boys
well becca that was a little bit soggy
but was successful huh
[Music]
well i'm back at the campsite and i
gotta admit i'm a little cold so i'm
gonna get the fire going try to warm up
a little bit
there you go thank you
this is robbing my hot dog
hey
you burned your wiener
we have five species of salmon here in
alaska
and this is called a pink salmon or they
call them a humpy because they get a
hump on their back they start off super
silver out in the ocean
and then they start to change colors
when they get in your fresh water get
ready to spawn this one was still in the
ocean but he's already kind of
kind of changing these are not as
popular as other salmon to eat
but they taste pretty good smoked this
is why they call them pink salmon the
meat's pink all the other salmon have
red or orange meat
becca's helping me pack up the mats
let's see how it's going in here
how's it going becca
all right baby ready to go try out
another campsite let's do it
oh becca's drying out her pants
oh look at this belly there's a nice
spot
my sister melanie's going to be joining
us i think that's our spot right there
for the 10.
[Music]
we got a big thing of gummy snacks that
we brought back from our trip to england
wheat bins and soft pretzels you want
mustard
this is going to be oh mustard and
cheese oh soft pretzels with mustard and
cheese oh my weakness
we go get some water here
here come on dude grab the pump
oh
um good enough for them
i don't know i i
i yeah i don't have a problem with that
the whole
color line casting thing but i'm like
ladies ready for some cider oh thank you
there you go
there you go melanie
we're gonna go ahead and get dinner
going i got some lemon lime chicken
shish kebabs some bacon wrapped chicken
shish kebabs and i'm gonna make some
homemade flatbread to go with it you
know i might throw some honey butter on
it i don't know we'll to see what's
happening
oh i think oh it's just i was i i
like him you're good oh yeah
you like it
he's a hot dog kid
mommy is the best mom mommy is the best
best mom
there we go nice piece of bread covered
in cinnamon honey butter oh becca did
you like cinema and hannah better i love
it so much
what do you guys think you like it it's
so good so hot
this is how i'm gonna keep my wife and
my looks fade
to cooking skills hey babe there you go
there's some teeth oh thank you so much
herbal tea is good isn't it so good we
got a lot of really nice herbal teas on
our trip to england and we've been we've
been enjoying these
i think this is strawberry elderberry
mix like the bread yes sir
boys you got to eat up and sleep well
tonight because we are going fishing
tomorrow can we do hot water bottles oh
of course
they get sap there we go we got all the
sleeping bags laid out let's get some
boys in bed
gotta go extra extra strong on campouts
they didn't eat a lot of sugar yeah
there you go babe let's put one in my
bag and one in yours oh becca's doing
battle with the kids in the tent but i
need to get ready for fishing tomorrow
because me tom and nate are going to
float a river on that boat
well i got the boat all ready to go for
tomorrow the kids are in bed and asleep
i think i'm gonna put the camera down
and pack it up for the night i'm gonna
see you guys tomorrow morning
good morning
good morning jacob
meet daddy can we get up
dehydrated okay
you guys like your granola yeah got a
pretty easy breakfast today we're doing
hard-boiled eggs in mountain house
granola just add cold water to it and it
makes granola and milk
i'm not the hugest fan of hard-boiled
eggs but when they're warm and salted
pretty good fist
oh
there you go
there we go we're all packed up now we
got to get the boys on the river we
gotta go catch some salmon
you guys ready
all right guys we're on the river
we're gonna give this a go i have
floated this river several times but
never as the guy behind the oars so this
is gonna be a first for me but we've got
about a three hour float trip if we just
go straight through but we want to stop
and fish along the way we're gonna try
to catch some sockeye salmon but we
might catch some trout or dollies too
check out all those dead trees up there
those are all killed by the japanese
spruce bark beetle the invasive beetle
from japan oh i think we get our first
taste of rapids
we got an anchor on the front of the
boat with a little bit of a pulley
system here and i just dropped the
anchor and uh we're gonna try doing a
little fishing and get a little bit of
lunch
for lunch the boys are getting banana
nutella sandwiches here
all right there we go
you guys like going down rivers like
this yes i mean oh do you see any socks
here that bald eagle just sitting right
there
see right there in the grass that bald
eagle was like riffing grass up
flying off with a big wad of grass
this is a good looking spot
maybe it was not making the place
you got a fish
you got a nice truck nathan nathan oh
you guys don't reel it up all the way
keep moving the water keep it going
here bring it up
nice rainbow tub
let's get him in the water well he
pulled this spot and tommy nailed an
18-inch rainbow trout right off the
get-go just absolute chaos
oh you got one
oh
keep that up keep your rod up swing it
[Music]
man
there we go
this guy was crazy he had someone's fly
stuck in him and lying all wrapped
around him where others failed we
succeeded like oh that's what happened
to my fly
that fish pulled so hard it pulled our
boat off anchor and i had to pull up the
anchor and row us in while nathan was
fighting it
now i gotta reposition the boat
oh there you go tom
show me what you got
nice stick top let's
we're gonna we're gonna let him go
though this has been a great spot but we
gotta keep moving down the river
and then you help
so we've anchored up here in the curtain
i've checked out the wiggle warts on the
left and right and they're just sitting
in the current wiggling about halfway
between the top and the bottom of the
water now sockeye salmon don't eat when
they're in the river
but they do get really irritable when
the trout get too close to them and so
what you're hoping is that these wiggle
warts tick them off and they'll go and
nip at the tail like they do with the
trout and then we get to hook them up
just don't jerk it tommy keep the right
touch
did he smoke are you
okay
no problem you want to try again yes
please get off
no
here bring him over
oh
he's right
there we go tom awesome was that awesome
yes high five
yes yes there we go
congratulations a nice pair of sockeye
salmon guys you guys have done real well
i think we need a full acre get out of
here guys mom's probably wondering where
we're at
i can see it there's the
landing speed
yeah
nothing that's what they've been eating
yeah
there we go
got a ton of meat and a ton of bait
let's go see mama and jake see how
they're doing
well listen guys if you enjoyed watching
this as much as we enjoyed doing it make
sure to click subscribe to the outdoor
boys youtube channel we put out new
videos every saturday morning i'll see
you guys then if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]